i'm speaking today with milo
yiannopoulos
milo is a hard man to categorize
part journalist part performance artist
part agent provocateur part comedian at
whit and witt
yiannopoulos is a man of immense and
complex self-contradiction
he's half greek and half irish but is
known as an englishman to the americans
with whom he has communicated
extensively
he's gay and jewish by dissent
he married his long-term boyfriend an
african-american man in hawaii in 2017
but faces frequent accusations of racism
he is or was strangely attractive to
young american republicans and completed
a successful and controversy-ridden tour
of us universities in 2016 and 2017.
for at least two years he was one of the
most well-known internet celebrities
let's say on the political front caused
more uproar than any other single person
that i can think of
he collected his fair share of enemies
along the way
he's often accused for example of being
an alt-right supporter an accusation
justified in the view of those who
oppose him by his association with
breitbart for whom he was an editor
in my view for what it's worth
milo was such a figure of inner
contradiction and outer controversy that
i believed from the beginning that his
time was numbered
nonetheless the circumstances of his
demise were unpredictable i would say
and that's in keeping with his apparent
destiny
after revealing details of his early
sexual experiences at the hands of a 29
year old priest whom he refused to name
he stated that he was an active
participant in the events and that such
occurrences were far more common and far
more consensual than people were willing
to admit
i don't think he ever recovered from the
controversy that those comments
generated
i should finish by saying that milo is
definitely now on the list of those who
no one acceptably socially should ever
speak to which i suppose is one of the
reasons why i'm talking to him
i want to know what happened to him in
his own words and i don't really give a
damn if that's politically incorrect
thanks milo for agreeing to be on my
channel and podcast
thank you very much for having me um i
take a slightly less fatalistic view of
my prospects than your introduction
would suggest um but uh
certainly i went through an
extraordinary
tumble
and i'm happy to share my thoughts about
it with you
yeah well let's let's start by reviewing
some of your history if you wouldn't
mind
tell me tell me let's start with a bit
of your history in the uk before you
came to the us it's been long enough so
that i think some biographical
information would be useful for people
so
tell me tell me about your your life in
the uk before you came to the us
then let's start talking about what
happened to you as soon as you came over
to north america
sure
um i had a very unhappy life
this particular particularly very
unhappy 20s
in london i started off as a journalist
in some quite prestigious publications
um i was in a relationship that was
i don't think uh healthy or happy for
either person involved
i
was searching i think i was looking i
couldn't work out yet
what i was what i was for what my my
purpose was
and it wasn't until
i got to america i discovered what it
was but i i started to
explore at least what would eventually
become my
um
i suppose my civic function as bomb
thrower and provocateur
uh right at the beginning of my career
in journalism i mean i
i was fairly predictably come from a
broken home not much love for for or
from either parent
um
and i started i
got lucky combination i guess of luck
and talent um writing for the telegraph
which is the most prestigious newspaper
in britain
and
i began to notice the gap between the
world that i was being asked to describe
and the world that i could see existed
at the time i was writing about
technology i was being asked to say that
um
women were having a dreadful time of it
in the emerging startup ecosystem in
london which as far as i could tell was
the
exact opposite of the truth
um
and eventually these sort of fishes got
wider and wider to the point where i
i sort of had this this moment where i
realized that my profession was a crock
of you know what
uh and then if i wanted to if i wanted
to do something worthwhile with my life
i should either
blow it up from the inside by being one
or pick something else to do
and
that was around the time that i
attracted the attention of breitbart the
site in the us
and i started from london writing from
breitbart in the u.s and that time i
didn't know what it was i never met
andrew breitbart and i didn't know who
he was either
anybody knew what it was or who what it
was to begin with it's a funny thing
when you look at things in retrospect
you know you get
involved with
people in organizations that develop a
particular way over time and then it
looks
from a historical perspective like that
was self-evident from the beginning but
certainly not when you're dealing with a
new organization
yeah i mean it was newish i don't think
that the values of breitbart changed a
lot but i think perhaps it's
uh it's modus operandi i think perhaps
the way that it conducted itself as an
organization
shifted into high gear
when steve bannon and i were there and i
was doing the cultural stuff and steve
was using the rest of the site as a sort
of battering ram politically
so i i mean i bear a lot a large part of
the responsibility for breitbart
becoming what it eventually became
although i don't think they've held on
to that legacy very well um i think it's
a little sad the way that they're
sort of
when i was there we used to make the
news and now they're sort of chasing off
the turning point um you know with
stories that could have been written in
2015-16
um i don't think they've managed to
maintain the
uh culturally defining excitement that
was there when i was there which i think
is a function of me and steve working
together
um
i suppose my center of gravity just
started shifting to the us
i started getting invitations to go and
speak at colleges
uh and sooner or later one day i just
sort of thought that there were six of
them in a row so i thought there was no
point flying home between them i might
as well just stay um and just do sort of
college after college and then suddenly
i found
myself booking more of them and
wondering why i should bother going home
and my center of gravity editorially and
and
in in other ways was shifting to the us
too so i
over the course of six or nine months
began writing more about the states
thinking more about the states
being in it talking about it um
and then
i suppose fast forward
a year perhaps and i
was
one of the two or three people
driving you know breitbart as this
extraordinary
momentous um
[Music]
fascinating dysfunctional editorial
force through the last election
so what was it that attracted you do you
think to the united states and the
political concerns there
why away from the uk
i don't think britain
handles iconoclasts very well and it
particularly doesn't handle bombastic
ones
and i think a lot of people with
outsized personalities
find themselves
investigating america as an alternative
birth because
i think america has a much higher
tolerance for um outsized personalities
yeah well i mean it's pretty clear that
you had some of the characteristics that
made people that make people stars you
know that make people personalities that
was obvious pretty much from the step
with the first this is why i'm not
worried in the long term about my career
prospects you know i had a
stratospheric rise over a couple of
years and uh you know a painful tumble
but talent is talent and talent always
wins um and i've got 40 years ahead of
me uh you know of whatever i choose to
do with it so i'm not worried in the
long term about my career prospects well
we can talk about your your dissent and
and the
sort of catastrophe that accompanied it
and maybe about how you see
yourself pulling
yourself how you see
being pulled out of that i'd like to
hear about that as well
so
what in the world do you think made you
so attractive to american republicans i
mean
this is one of the things that struck me
about you right from the beginning
because it's not exactly like you're a
poster boy for
what
you would assume a conservative american
republicans would be attracted to
so
well i think they quite liked the fact
that i was
reflecting their views in a package that
you would more often think would be a
liberal and of course i you know made
that part of the act and part of the
brand it's kind of like you know all
these things and yet still republican
but the real answer is joy
there's a there's a joylessness about
a lot of conservative activist authors
and speakers and there's a joylessness
in intellectual dark web too
it's a very funless place
and
i look at i look out at the
public intellectuals and commentators
and speakers who are currently enjoying
a um
a moment in the sun
and each of them is in their own way
quite joyless
quite devoid of mirth and i think that
people liked
my sense of mischief and mice and they
liked the fact that i was always smiling
and i think it's like
i mean it's it's
unusual to see somebody talking about
really serious things who is the subject
of the most extraordinary and relentless
abuse who nonetheless is always smiling
and i
have always been that person i've never
stopped not in 2017-18 or today um i
think people find that very mesmerizing
and very attractive because
and very perplexing and difficult to
understand given the circumstances and
the apparent seriousness of the topics
you know i mean there is something that
is
i i think it's i think it's to do with
i mean you know joy is christianity's
great gift to western civilization
laughter you know the medieval church is
you know this place of song and of dance
um i think christianity has become quite
joyless the only places where there's a
really um
impassioned happy spirit of worship is
in black churches
but
white evangelical protestantism in in
the u.s has become
i think uh quite suffocating and joyless
i think public the public square as a
whole
in general is a miserable place twitter
is a miserable place if you turn the
television on people are miserable um i
think there's a there's something about
me that something may be missing in my
brain that doesn't get ground down by it
and i'm watching you know i had
my you know moment in the sun some other
people are having a moment in the sun
now that will you know uh that too will
pass and i'm watching them and i'm
watching them all getting ground down
i'm well how do you well that's a good
that's a real question it's of interest
to me from a psychological perspective i
mean
um you know my suspicions it's obviously
that you're extremely extroverted
i'm not claiming any particular
brilliance for
noting that and also that you're
extremely open and that's the creativity
dimension but i'm wondering about your
scores on neuroticism it's like you were
you were subject to a tremendous amount
of controversy
and and then uh
quite a precipitous fall under strange
and
complicated circumstances
you seem to be able to
survive that and you just described
yourself as a relatively joyful person i
mean i'm a very happy person i think
that
listen i mean you know the conservatives
are only
um
out
and off the playing field when they
choose to be
uh
because there's such a this there's so
few of us in such a wide open market um
the reason i'm not worried about my
prospects in the long term is i still
wake up every day with joy in my heart
brimming with energy and ideas most i
don't know anybody in public life not
one person in public life
who could have
gone through what i went through and not
been broken by it but i'm not
um it hasn't beaten me and i think that
that's a com down to a combination of of
personal characteristics that i don't
think many other people possess
and
that's
part of that is
you know not being uh no i i it's
impossible to intimidate me for instance
i don't get scared of things i'm not
scared of people
um
i don't
feel uh
perhaps to the same degree that other
people do embarrassment and shame so i
don't mind um
playing fool playing falstaff clowning
you know i don't mind subverting myself
laughing at myself because because
through that i'm able to point to to
truths that are real and and big and
beautiful and important
um
i'm not an egotist so i don't and i
think that's part of the same thing i
don't mind humbling myself
because i
play at having a big ego but i don't
really
and i'm not
ground down or broken or upset by
things that you know that don't matter
that much i mean i have love in my life
i have achieved more than
99.8
of
journalists political activists uh you
know public figures you and i are the
only people who have achieved remotely
close to our level of success in our you
know in the last 10 years worth of
conservative idw you know uh whatever
whatever this
grand nexus
ecosystem is that we both belong to you
and are the only two people who you know
you you know that's the two who have
achieved the greatest success at it um
and i've had terrible things happen to
me you're fortunate and nothing nothing
bad has really happened to you yet
um
i can't think of anything really awful
that's happened to you aside from the
cambridge thing which i think that i
like well i wouldn't call that i
i think you brought that on yourself and
i don't think it was too much of a big
deal anyway um but nothing really bad
has happened to you yet the worst thing
imaginable has happened to me i had to
stand up uh in front of the world and
tell them
that i had been sexually abused as a
child and that this was why i'd spoken
loosely and uncautiously and used a
formulation that i regretted about
something that had happened to me
and at the same time try to make try to
also say well i'm not going to stop
making jokes about that or anything else
um for other people i think that level
of
of public ritual humiliation would
simply have snapped them
and it didn't me
and i don't know i mean you're the
you're the psychology expert perhaps you
have a some insight of you on this the
only person i know in my personal life
friend who has similar qualities is ann
coulter
um
to whom criticism is
it's a game
and she's able to very
an interesting thing is not you know
it's not it's not enough to say that
we're
let's say sociopathic because quite
clearly we're both not
wouldn't be able to
have some of the insights we do and we
wouldn't have the love in our lives that
we do if we were sociopathic so it's not
that but we do both have an ability to
just pick things up put them over there
uh and not allow them to
to burrow in and have and create well
that seems that seems to me to be that
relatively rare combination of extreme
extroversion and very low neuroticism
that's not the same as sociopathy i
think you're right about that i think
maybe that's what i've got
some people are just not that affected
emotionally by negative events you know
some people are devastated by the
smallest of obstacles and some people
can roll with punches that would take a
normal person out and continue to get
back up and certainly
things do bother me in my personal life
but the things that are actually
significant whether it's to do with my
family
or
you know
my loved one or whatever it is there are
things that i that in my brain are
emotionally significant serious things
worthy of um
unfettered access to my emotions if you
like and they have that and they produce
very strong reactions in both directions
i'm a very passionate person i can even
be hot-headed you know when i'm
defending somebody i love for instance
but there's another world which is the
professional world which is to me
just a just a big game it's a big fun
game and
this
the reason why i've always thought of
you as a kind of a trickster
you know i mean i think that's possible
that that you do there is a game-like
element to what you're doing
and and i very much see what i'm doing
in life and we'll be doing for the next
40 years as playing a very complex and
very enjoyable uh game of uh and very uh
you know a game of snakes and ladders
and just because i
hit a ladder on one of my first turns
and then immediately the snake took me
back to the front row it doesn't mean
the game is over uh you know it in fact
it just means you've you've learned the
rules
so
that's i suppose why i find it difficult
to take too seriously you know
um harrowing introspection about you
know whatever because it just it's not
how i apprehend the situation i can look
dispassionately what happened and why
and we can talk about that and i have
some ideas about that um
but
i don't have a
i don't have a sort of emotional i don't
have anything to offload about it
really okay okay well so
you know
when
when that conversation about your
early
childhood sexual experiences first came
out i listened to it and i thought
that there was tremendous trouble
brewing there you know
for a variety of reasons and if you
remember i phoned you at that point and
suggested that we had a conversation and
we made some efforts to manage that that
never came to fruition and i always felt
that that was unfortunate
and so
i'd like to if you don't mind i'd like
to ask you about
that situation
because
you know i had a lot of mixed feelings
about what you said
unlike many people and they weren't
particularly judgmental by the way i
mean
so
you
you correct me if i'm wrong here because
i want to get this story straight
you related some experiences you had
with a priest
who was twice your age right something
like that yeah approximating
approximately that you were about 14
i think he was a little older than that
actually
okay okay he was a little older it's
difficult to judge ages when you are 14.
i think i thought i think i thought that
he was younger than he was
at the time
and subsequently found out he was
perhaps 10 years older than i thought he
was
but there was a but there was a
significant age gap yeah yeah and and so
arguably
he was someone who is in a position of
authority
and that
what he did with you was something that
he shouldn't have done and also it's
highly probable given the nature of such
things that you are by no means his only
let's say target
now
when i heard you talk about that the
first thing that struck me about the way
that you formulated it was
your refusal to play victim
now actually i didn't see myself as one
i know i know i know that i know that
and that actually struck me as rather
admirable because you
came forward and said
um this is an uncomfortable
truth but you know i was of sufficient
age to have a mind of my own and this
was something i was pursuing of my own
volition and then it's how i felt at the
time and you know when you talk about
the the abusive authority or whatever
i've never met an authority i recognize
or respect you know people have to earn
my respect i have never encountered a
person in a position of responsibility
or authority who i have respected and
and deferred to merely by virtue of
their office or their position right
absolutely
i sort of constitutionally don't
recognize authority so that element of
it did not strike me until someone
told me okay okay well that's the thing
okay so well i can imagine that because
i don't imagine that you were much
different in some sense when you were 14
than you are now you know apart from
obvious maturation you're you know
you're you're a
assertive and provocative person and
you're an iconoclast and i can certainly
see that
that intrinsic respect for authority
which so oddly often characterizes
conservatives by the way is quite absent
in you
and so and i thought
that's the tabloid gadfly constantly
taking pot shots at the
uh institutions that you also secretly
love and are grateful for but you
are dedicated to keeping them on the
ground and not
you know it's the difference between
you know the the british tabloids which
love to torment our prime minister and
the white house correspondents dinner
where journalists are seeking to
participate in that prestige rather than
um
bring these people down to earth and
make sure they never go a full day
taking themselves too seriously uh so i
think that's a perhaps a british it's a
bit of a british
a bit of a british psyche right right
that seems given my
interactions with british journalists
that seems like a perfectly appropriate
statement now
despite the fact that when i heard you
speak about what happened to you
and my
admiration for your refusal
to play innocent victim
i also had
contradictory ideas that i think were
more a function of my clinical training
and there were two of them that i'd like
to discuss with you i mean the first is
you know when you think about yourself
as a 14 year old you think about that 14
year old as as yourself
you don't necessarily think about that
14 year old as a 14 year old and you
know when you remember your 14 year old
self and then you go out and you see
some 14 year olds it's actually quite a
shock or it can be quite a shock because
14 year olds are often a lot younger and
a lot more clueless
yeah then you remember yourself being
you know i think i know where you're
going with this and i and i
well and so so good good well because
the second part of what i thought was
that
like
it
and and this is this the incredibly
tricky part of this conversation as far
as i'm concerned i mean one of the other
things that got you in real trouble
apart from the fact that you wouldn't
name
your
the person that you interacted with your
abuser so to speak
was that you
made the unforgivable case i think
publicly
that this sort of thing happened far
more commonly than people were willing
to admit and i just as soon as you said
that i thought man you're you're dead in
the water because it was interesting
well true that may be it's not something
that can be publicly discussed it's not
you know in it
i went a bit further though than just
that i took it i took it a step further
even and said that not only is this
something that happens far more often
than people are willing to admit it
is a function of gay life and gay right
uh
adolescence blossom whatever and um it
is a proper subject for humor and i
insist on it being a proper subject yeah
well i wasn't even gonna bring those two
things up because i thought that just
you know that merely bringing up the
first part of that would cause enough
trouble but i'm glad that you did bring
the second part of that up well because
there's a serious conversation that has
to be had about this and the damn
conversation hasn't happened and i don't
mean specifically about
even specifically about your
particular experience although i think
it's a way into the conversation it's
like the first question is
well it'd be it'd be interesting to take
apart some of your claims and i'd like
to do that with your permission and i
don't expect this to be an easy
conversation no that's i wasn't
expecting to be so go ahead okay okay so
the first thing i would say is that
it isn't obvious to me that even if you
were a willing participant in what
happened to you when you were 14
that that
justifies
what happened to you
on the part of the person with whom you
were participating
well of course it doesn't but the way i
apprehended it
was that it was me
right
but but and and when i said a moment ago
i think i know where you're going with
this i can interject with a very small
data point that i think explains
how i think about this after some time
and reflection which is i have something
now that i didn't have in 2017 which is
a relationship with my stepson
and
he is 16.
when i think
let's not
leave let's not finish that thought but
when i consider how old he is and put
myself at that age
suddenly the horror that i see in
everybody else's faces that i have never
felt myself about what happened to me
and therefore has never
been it's never been communicated for me
a sort of acknowledgement and awareness
that this is not normal and that that
this is a
horrifying and terrible things that
happened to
a small person i never apprehended it
like that because i just thought of that
14 year old as me today right right okay
and that's exactly what i picked look
that's exactly what i picked up from
your from your interview until the last
two years
and now i'm and now i'm i'm
experiencing getting to know a child
yeah
as a
co-parent
yeah as a stepmom
and now i get it okay now okay okay all
right so you know i've seen this with my
clinical clients you know who
who
failed to notice in some important way
that the person they were sometimes
decades ago
is not the person they are now and the
memories they have from those times
which are
appropriate to those times
are not the same memories that are
appropriate to those times now given
their relative maturation
i think that's fair and i think it took
that
change in my life circumstances for me
to to jolt me into realizing uh exactly
what you're saying
okay so let's so let me ask you some
questions about that
so
what
what's
what's changed in the way that you view
what happened to you and if you were
interviewed well and i guess you are
being interviewed about this right now
if you were being interviewed about what
happened to you at age 14 i have two
questions or three questions about that
what do you think of the propriety of
that
how do you now view your role
what do you think about the culpability
of the person that
that
i would say
in common parlance preyed upon you
how is that shifted
in the same way that there is um
although it has been ruined by
the progressives we both hate so much um
a proper place for outrage
it is unnecessary and right
human instinct and emotion that has a
place
there is also perhaps
much as it has been ruined by the
progressives a proper place for
victimhood when you are in fact actually
a victim right and i think that now i
perhaps realized that i was one when i
didn't know that i was one in 2017. yeah
that's a hell of a thing for someone in
your position to admit
right
yeah yeah no it's it's rough man and i
and i think that that's as concise and
as true and answer as
i can give you
um
and i think okay so let's let's go into
a little bit of the answer because now i
i i look at somebody i care about who is
two years older even
um
and the thought of me at that age and
someone taking advantage suddenly i get
it i get it i'm like i would kill the
guy i would walk over there i would
shoot him in the head
like i get it now you know okay
i didn't get it when i was
i didn't get it
when all i had to go on was my memories
of being me at the time yeah
well one of the things that struck me is
so absolutely absurd about what happened
to you in the aftermath of that
interview was that i thought
okay this is really
and it's exactly what i would have
expected to happen to someone like you
because you're so contradictory is that
is that
you actually had a claim to victim
status
which you then refused to capitalize on
and then which people refused to bloody
well recognize in the midst of the
interview like the proper response to
that interview should have been
something like
well here's someone who's talking about
a case of child sexual abuse but hasn't
realized or recognized that they were in
fact
victimized in that situation and hasn't
come to terms with whatever that might
mean
and so that's not uncommon
among people who have been through these
experiences because i have since writing
about this i wrote a little bit about
this in the uh in
a short book i read about the pope
recently
um
and and another things i've i've
the brief mentions i've made of it since
2017 a lot of people have written to me
with their own
accounts
and this is not uncommon
i have no idea no i'm sure it's not who
have experienced this sort of thing and
i guess there's some point in middle age
where the penny drops
but yeah um i i guess that i guess you
know there is there is a right and
proper place to acknowledge and
understand that you're a victim of
something again i have to
another thing that upset people i think
another thing that
didn't do many favors but look i
i am someone who
will always
just speak it as i see it and that will
have terrible consequences and all have
great consequences
and that calculus will change over the
course of the next few decades but um
i just um
it wasn't the worst thing that ever
happened to me
and people find that a terrible thing to
come out of your mouth but it just
wasn't it's not the worst thing that's
ever happened to me and
so what's the worst thing okay so so i
got a couple of comments on that i mean
about
20 years ago
the american psychological association
published a famous paper
showing that
most people who were sexually abused as
children
recovered with very little psychological
damage and that caused absolute outrage
the us congress in fact forced the apa
if i remember correct the american
psychological this is one of those
unsavable truths isn't it well they had
to retract they had to retract the
article even though if you imagine the
sort of trauma that we're expected to
recognize
uh that someone uh says they experience
because of mean words on the internet
and and we have this in we have this
economy based on um
what we all know is not true but that
you know these trivial frivolous things
can cause some kind of actual trauma
for an organization like that or for
someone in public life to to come out
and say this huge thing
actually didn't cause me that much
trauma
it sort of imperils the whole victimhood
economy doesn't it because
if it's the case that
many or even most people who experience
this simply don't have their lives
ruined and defined by it
that rather imperils the people who have
made a career out of
squawking victimhood for far far less
serious experiences and i think that's
probably where
the threat to the system kicked in
whereas
i think i think that's true i think it's
also the case that the politicians
although also looking for a you know a
cheap victory moral victory in some
sense we're also concerned that
this was a potential
uh step towards
justifying pedophilia on the basis of
undermining the claims of its absolutely
catastrophic consequences over
decades whereas what i saw it was was
more as a testament to the fundamental
resilience of human beings right isn't
it isn't that a positive thing isn't
that wonderful news that there is there
are these extraordinarily evil people
who do depraved things but the chances
are you'll be all right you know that
something like this could happen to you
or could happen to somebody you love or
somebody you know
but that you know what chances are
things will be okay now every once in a
while somebody is just blown apart by it
and you can never put them back together
but that's not most people that's
fabulous news but good news is the sort
of thing that
our current political climate the public
square in america especially hates
it's not so much whether it it it's a
particular kind of reaction to for
instance um
people being people being uh uh grateful
and happy that capitalism is is you know
lifting millions of people out of
poverty all over the world people don't
like that good news right
because because
much of what
goes on in in public life basically the
whole journalism industry
much of the entertainment industry i
mean the the whole of polite society the
whole of political politically correct
society depends upon
everything being terrible
in peril getting worse all the time um
the sort of shrieking urgent hysteria of
the press is
made to look ridiculous when you point
out actually the world's pretty great
not that people not that many people go
hungry uh not that much bad stuff
happens the bad stuff that does happen
we're discovering all the time that
human beings bounce back in ways that
you know we never never even imagined
the world ain't that bloody bad nobody
wants to hear that who has invested in
it
or if it at least if it isn't isn't
it at least it's nowhere near as bad as
it once was which is something or as bad
as as bad as it profits
the media to suggest that it is profits
the academy to suggest that it is you
know it it these people these people are
having
having relinquished their primary phone
whether it is you know speaking truth to
power and um you know printing over the
news that you know relaying the news is
fit to print or
exploring the human condition human
nature and you know building the you
know
expanding the you know the horizons and
the some total of human knowledge that
the media and the academy have given up
on those missions instead replace them
with an activism that depends on
hysteria but also on urgency um on a
sort of there's a sort of constant
drumbeat this is why you know it's
always something new or something new
always something new as soon as
something might look like it's resolved
something ever more hysterical and new
must be produced this is this i mean
this is the natural life cycle isn't it
of rights movements you've got the gay
rights movement which basically achieves
everything you could possibly ever want
yet it somehow becomes more hysterical
not less and starts focusing on ever
more minor and insignificant things like
transgender pronouns rather than aids um
you know and now all of the gay
charities are run by lesbians and are
preoccupied with um transgender pronouns
you don't hear anybody talking about the
fact that um thanks you know
you see there's these these posters on
uh new york uh uh trams on the subway uh
whatever they're called um
and they and they're saying um oh uh
there's a guy there and he's called
hernandez uh or hernandez or whatever uh
and his um and the poster is saying his
uh levels of hiv thanks to his
medication aren't just undetectable
they're not transmittable either
basically encouraging gay men to have
sex with hiv-positive other men yeah i
mean it's kind of like sick this is
because conservatives have completely
stepped out of that sphere entirely
every time a conservative tries to say
something um in the gay world even if
it's with good intentions to help they
get killed so so republicans and even
it's all sensible people have simply
stepped out of lgbt stuff and they just
don't get involved in it at all
so you get this sick crazy like mental
so with this you know this situation
where they're encouraging these reckless
unsafe horrendous behaviors and who
suffers
the most marginalized communities of all
so you know it's a
gay black americans i have like a one in
two chance of getting hiv yeah right
like that's that's crazy and this is you
know and this is this is this is what
gay charities are not talking about
while they are insisting that you know
on on
them or whatever but this is this is the
life cycle of rights movements when they
run out of things to complain about
isn't it
okay so let me let me ask you another
personal question
um
before i turn to something that will
probably get me even more trouble in
more trouble
we'll see we'll see how that goes but
you've subjected me to a therapy session
i think you can you can uh
you can you can get yourself into
trouble as uh as compensation yeah yeah
yeah okay well
there should be plenty of trouble emerge
from this so well look now
one of the questions i had again as a
consequence of watching that interview
was because
you know you portrayed yourself as an
equivalent partner in some sense and i
thought look that means that milo hasn't
updated his memories
they're still the memories of a 14 year
old and that that's a problem
and
and and so and you said that that's
something that you've actually rectified
over the last couple of years and so
that's that's a very interesting thing
to hear about
but then i was also
convinced
that because you were still viewing what
had happened to you through the lens of
your 14 year old your iconoclastic and
rebellious 14 year old self
that it was possible
likely even
although not necessarily the case that
you underestimated the consequence of
this interaction on your subsequent life
and so now you just told me that you
know much worse things have happened to
you yes
yeah yeah you might be right about that
because in 2017 that's what i thought
and then in the course of writing the
the short pope book i just did i asked
the question
could this have affected the trajectory
of my sexuality
yeah well i i wonder if what's exactly
well so so what what in retrospect now
what do you think
what do you think it did to you
i don't think it made the difference
between me being gay or not
okay and why not
because i think that that was already
happening
and i think that i was aware of that and
that that was very much
you know some gay people talk about you
know being a little bit over into gay
or a lot or whatever you know some gay
men can can
countenance or imagine
having sex with women
um
and for for others it's just like you
know in the way that straight men will
talk about homosexual encounters
uh now i have had a few encounters with
women but they were very unsatisfying
and miserable for both parties um
and
i think i'm quite i don't i don't
my hunch is and i can't provide any
evidence with my hunches
that this did not make the difference
okay i i think that um
like everybody the mixture of nature and
nurture in my case was probably swung
over in that direction by a lack of good
male role models and my relationship
with my mother
i distinctly remember
picking
um
ethnic minority male sexual partners
and making sure that my mother saw me
bring them home or saw me out with them
to antagonize her
i distinctly remember picking sexual
partners to annoy my mom and that as
demented as that sounds
and god that's a that's that's uh chris
i mean like a three-hour conversation no
i mean look i take trolling very
seriously
[Laughter]
um
i i i just i'm not saying i went to
annoy my mom although i have made that
joke before but i remember an element of
sort of mischief and defiance in there
which has always been at the core of my
personality just this
this reflexive
and
unshakable refusal to bow to any kind of
authority right and so what were you
more than that also
not but not just to thumb my nose at it
but to rub that authority's
face in whatever it is that that
authority finds the most repugnant okay
well so that's interesting so the first
question there would be
perhaps
what in the world were you so
irritated or angry at your mother about
that that might have been one of your
potential reactions
i have said this in public before so i
don't mind sharing it with you again
uh my mother remarried and her new
husband was um
occasionally physically and
constantly psychologically you know
abusive i guess with the word that we
would use now um
a deeply
unpleasant home life
in things like so i was a very proud
private kid and i had all of these like
um
papers where i had written out poems and
and
constructed these like systems and i
just i just had a very highly developed
in a world you know and i've just lived
in the realm of imagination and fantasy
and
private space and privacy was very
important to me and my mother's new
husband when i was at school would go
into my room and shuffle things around
just so that i knew he'd been in there
so i knew that there was no space that
was only mine and i knew by extension
that i wasn't welcome there and that i
shouldn't be there and that so long as i
was under his roof i would never be my
own human being and i would never have
my own
privacy and therefore autonomy as a as a
human being and i blamed my mother for
this i also blamed my
mother for
not leaving him when he hit me
um
and i blamed my father for not taking me
away although i asked him to
and that sort of began a chain reaction
of resentment for both of them right so
okay so most of the major authority
figures in your life as parental figures
had
your experience at that point was of
a betrayal of various meg
various magnitudes right yeah they did
they didn't have my back right it from
from from proper betrayal
all the way down to just
not having my best interest at heart not
having my back and and you know all
manner of experiences on that spectrum
but i didn't think i ever felt
like
my mother would go to the wall for me
you know right right that's yeah that's
rough man because one of the things you
really want from at least one parent or
at least one person in your life is the
notion that
fundamentally
man you got to have someone who's got
your back
i did get it later i did get it later in
my mid to late teens with my grandmother
um
as so many um
oddballs do they end up skipping a
generation uh and and forming a close
bond with a grandparent
um i did get it from my grandmother and
i got the sort of unconditional love and
support that i
recognized again in the man that i'm now
with um so i have had that since in my
life and i'm not wanting for it i don't
lack it i'm very happy with the amount
of it that i now have
but i didn't made up for it in some
sense
oh for sure oh for sure um but i didn't
but i didn't have it at the time
and i do remember really wanting them to
hurt
i remember and
i i think one of my
in addition to my ability to sort of see
around corners and culturally and sort
of tell what's coming next which i'm
very good at i'm also very good
i'm very good at sort of intuitively
figuring out what makes people tick and
what drives them
and i quickly identified that social
justice warriors were sort of hurting
and wanting everyone else to hurt like
they were
um when i when i very very first started
doing my speeches
because it was something i had felt
myself but only as a child i had grown
out of it and clearly they had not grown
out of it right but i saw in them that
same sort of petty vengeful vindictive
desire to make the world burn uh because
they were hurting that i had felt myself
as a 13 14 15 year old
and so i understood them and that's why
i was able
and still am able like nobody else to
get under their skin
because i get what makes them tick in a
way that not many other people do
because
none of the other conservatives who are
sort of you know withering you know or
contemptuous of them actually understand
where they're coming from like i do uh
which is why they hate me like they hate
nobody else
right well because i part of the thing
that's so strange about you is that by
all rights you should be on their side i
should be one of them really
i ought to be
right right that's there that's that's
right
logically speaking that would be your
natural resting place and so it is one
of the things that well i also thought
right from the beginning that that was
one of the things that put you in in
terrible
long-term danger of you know
encountering a scandal that would do you
in i mean it just seemed so
improbable to me that you could weather
that degree of and that's what i mean by
the paradoxical combination that you
bring to the situation it's just it's
too many contradictory things to
maintain themselves
regardless of your psychological
integration or lack thereof
i mean i think i'm pretty well adjusted
now but um
i think perhaps another reason that this
career stuff just doesn't bother me is
that i don't
i don't work in the same economy that a
lot of other people do in the prestige
economy
um you wanted prestige when you asked
cambridge for that fellowship um and you
sort of invited that little
embarrassment on yourself because you
asked for it because although you've
declared well they said i asked for it
but that wasn't exactly if you didn't he
didn't but you declared war on a class
of institutions
um you know a higher education to then
uh
ask for or expect or be pleased to
receive baubles
from
institutions that you declared war on
struck me as very odd and
obviously destined for you know a mess
and that's an interesting point and it's
because the moment of like false
optimism
i don't think it's false optimism i
think it's i think it's because you
still live in the prestige economy
because i think that stuff matters to
you um and i think that you'd probably
prefer to see these institutions fixed
and to have a prestigious place within
one of them rather than to see them
burnt to the ground as so many
conservatives and
progressives seem to want they just want
to tear up higher education i don't
think you want that i think you want to
fix it and i think you want to be
creative i think generally speaking you
know
that fixing things is better than
burning them to the ground
well i think you want to fix them and i
think you want to be one of their crown
jewels and i think you operate in the
prestige economy in a way that i simply
don't and that gives me power because
i don't care
i don't you know that's sort of like a
scandal from which you will not recover
is there somebody in polite society who
will invite me to a dinner party uh who
won't invite me to a dinner party now
who would have in january 2017.
no is there a tv show that will have me
on
that won't have me on now but would have
in january in january
no i mean i you know i had a blip on
bill maher because of the the college
tour but there was no hope in hell no
way until i was ever gonna get a tv show
or anything like that because unlike you
i can't bite my tongue
um and
you know you you i think are
i see you maneuvering in a way that
suggests that you
want to do
a lot of good and you're prepared to
make some compromises in order to have a
platform which to do a lot of good in a
lot of places i'm a purist and we differ
in that because
i can't bite my tongue
and if i'm across the table from
somebody who is an odious piece of you
know what i'm like i'm going to tell
them and it's always it's my greatest
asset and my greatest weakness but it's
because i'm a purist in a way that
you're not
and
i just i don't live in that prestige
economy that the rest of you all live in
um and you all live in it everyone you
know the whole conservative libertarian
media ecosystem you all crave pressure
what do you mean by the what do you mean
by the prestige economy exactly like
position
a recognition
um
titles uh
being a part of a sort of alternative
polite society you don't want to be
excised from the church because if you
did you wouldn't have signed up with caa
you want to be part of the church um and
i don't
i i
and it can be very difficult for people
who are part of the prestige economy but
people who want the tv show want the
fancy agent want this want that one and
they want to like fix and rule these
institutions it can be very difficult
for those people to to truly understand
someone like me who genuinely can't
imagine anything worse
i cannot imagine
anything more awful than having to
make the sorts of constant compromises
in what i say and do in order to
maintain a position because i know it's
doomed anyway look at roger scrutin
uh you know did nothing wrong he is
beyond reproach he is uh you know he is
the foremost conservative intellectual
of
his generation
and
they just got him for saying something
utterly innocuous in an interview
they're gonna get you anyway nothing bad
has happened to you yet
but it's going to and i don't say that
with any pleasure whatsoever i sincerely
do not because i've been expecting that
for a very long period of time
many many bad things have happened to me
they just haven't told not
not really uh i mean in in
compared to what some of us have gone
through uh you know whether it's laura
or or me or whatever or alex jones or
whatever nothing really bad well fair
enough yes um you know that it doesn't
depend on your comparison group well uh
they they are allowing you to grow
i'll tell you what they'll do they're
doing with you what they did with me
which is you allow this this phenomenon
to blossom
up to the point you cannot bear it any
longer and then you crush it and that is
a horrifying warning to others
not to overstep
so they did it with me they let me get
as far as bill maher and the tour and
all the rest of it and then they came
for it
they're letting you climb higher um so
your fall is going to be dressed like
mine was and i'll get you on something
else
um they'll get you they'll get you on a
complete nothing burger because mine
let's face it was a nothing burger
it was you know the the
supposed scandal was predicated on an
edited video which did not show that i
said that i thought the age of consent
was about right
and it was based on it was based on a
lie
if it had been the case that everybody
had seen what i originally said they
might have said uh please explain this
but it would not have had the same
um effect
that it did it had the effect it did
because it was a deceptive dishonest
misleadingly edited video because i had
created enemies on both left and right
the establishment right and the whole
left teamed up to take me out
you are walking into the same position
so ed so why do you see that it was the
establishment right do you do you think
that that's what who did it
they're the ones who did it
it was the reagan well it was the reagan
battalion national review crowd who put
that video together and shared it they
were the ones who manufactured this
because they were upset that i didn't
give a stuff about cpac because it means
nothing to me i didn't even know what it
was at the time but they were upset that
i was speaking at cpac because it was it
was like their
precious
um
pure conservatism thing had been taken
over by trump world right right right
and they had to and so so they didn't
care so much about the bill maher but
the sort of the national review reagan
battalion crowd who created and
propagated and shared and and uh
whatever with this deceptively edited
video
did so because they couldn't bear the
thought of me being the star turn at
cpac okay and so and do you think that
that's why they pushed so hard on the
pedophilia front
yes because they knew it's the one thing
that the conservative base would go
yeah right and and the left didn't take
me out the right did
okay okay i wasn't aware of that
no well if the left took you out out too
as well so what power does the what
power does the left have over me what
are they doing to me now that they
weren't doing in january 2017 nothing
well i think i think what my my
impression i'm not suggesting that i'm
correct but my impression was that it
had something to do with the second of
the two or three topics we were going to
discuss which was your claim that the
experiences that you had are actually
very characteristic of the gay community
no you see interestingly what actually
happened about that specific thing is
the entire gay liberal establishment
went silent
because what i said was
and i wouldn't phrase this word phrase
it this way again because it was it was
not quite what i meant and it was
let's say uncautiously phrased to put it
mildly what i said was that
relationships between older men and
young i should have said younger men
are a common function of
gay life and i think i said
i'm afraid i think i said after a lot of
drinks on a late night live stream they
can be hugely positive experiences i
shouldn't have put it like that uh i
should have said they are a function of
gay life and in many cases they sitting
like a 35 year old man with a 20 year
old or whatever
very often that 35 year old will sort of
induct the 20 year old into the gay way
of things show them where the clubs are
uh show them the ropes um
in lieu of parents
because
because the boy's parents don't
understand him maybe don't even know um
or have rejected it or whatever so very
often there's a sort of father there's
there's either an evocular or a paternal
dimension to these relationships
on that point and indeed throughout the
in throughout the whole controversy the
gay left went silent and february 21st
2nd and 3rd 2017
gay journalists were nowhere to be found
in america because they did not want to
have that discussion because they know
it's true okay well so is that the
consequence of abandoning you by
inaction then no no no what i'm saying
is that that's not that that what i'm
saying is that that's not what was so
unforgivable that's not what that wasn't
that wasn't the problem
okay so so then well in that case then i
guess it's a matter of
not so much the difference in age but
the difference in which in when that age
difference starts so let's say well
so so we've had a conversation so far
um
which is presumed that the contents of
what i said was important and that we
should dissect it
this is a mistake
because it doesn't matter what i said
it doesn't matter whether it was right
to say it or what the nuances or
vagaries are of a particular statement
that i say is deceptively edited here or
whatever it doesn't matter
narrative was established and it was
repeated by right and left and the
person was ejected from you know from
public life and from whatever right this
is what's going to happen to you this is
what's going to happen to ben this is
what's going to happen to dave rubin um
because nobody stood up for me
the playbook became established and now
that is your fate all of you that's how
you're all going to go out
and it doesn't matter what you say it
doesn't matter what the subject was
doesn't matter what the in cautious
phrase was i mean candace owens it could
have could have happened to her recently
with her um
stupid her stupid she tripped over
herself saying something about hitler
and and you know there was a sentence
that i'm sure she would phrase
differently a second time everyone sort
of knew what she meant but it could it
could if the stars had
had aligned have done to her what
happened to me in february 2017. the
content doesn't matter it was the fact
that
the left and right decided to take this
person out and any pretext would have
done done fine
so we've had a discussion sort of
talking about what what was it you said
that was so unacceptable nothing
it was me
it was the fact that yeah but there's
also the mystery look fair enough you
know and i'm i'm not disputing that
that that there were any number of
reasons to make you a target but i am
curious about why it was that particular
interview that did it because it was
hard
because because
i was scheduled to be the star speaker
at cpac
and the national review crowd crowd
could not handle it
so they went through
the hours and hours and hours and hours
of old live streams and they found
something that would
uh
they found something that would um get
uh get to
the republican base
something they could sell to alienate me
from republicans
rather than just the left
and then they decided this person is
going to go
this is the power they still have and
it's a power they will
leverage against the rest of you too
my
question is
we can talk a little about where i'm
going to go next and what i'm going to
do next um
professionally because i i think it
might help the rest of you
uh when this inevitably happens to you
but
it's
this is a power they still have it is a
power that they
can and will
leverage against other people and
unfortunately the brightest star
and the greatest standard bearer the you
know the court jester of the movement
was allowed to be decapitated and
because that happened
the playbook is now established for it
to happen to everybody else and it will
happen to everybody else it's already
happening to other people you've seen it
happen since um to others right
um what happened to sargon of akkad
exactly
lesser in a lesser this is now how it's
going to be
and it didn't have to be like that
the only way that this
boycott and defenestration
could have been successful would be if
republicans refused to would have been
republican said okay we won't invite him
to anything we won't have him on our
radio shows um he's too hot to handle uh
too much drama too much hassle right
what the left does is
immediately start putting that person on
conference stages and panels to get over
that period of like oh is this person
going to become untouchable
they railroad they drive a truck through
that by immediately getting that person
on tv and on conference stages a lot to
sort of
to to you know to to drive through that
and to make sure that person doesn't get
removed from
circulation right that's what the left
does when something when linda sarsour
is discovered to have said something
awful
suddenly she's on conference stages
every two days it seems like you know
she's speaking in the box she's doing
this this is not an accident this is on
purpose this is the left
um uh leaping into action to ensure that
she survives right
conservatives did the opposite with me
they allowed the left and the
establishment republicans who hate them
um to dictate who would and would not
be a proper subject for discussion and
who should and should not have you know
a column and all the rest of it and
that's
that was
absolutely suicidal
okay and yeah and the reason that so
many other media figures were secretly
happy to see it happen to me is that
they're idiots who believe that this is
a zero-sum game
they think that by removing me
they create space for themselves this is
not true
there is nobody in the conservative or
libertarian ecosystem who offers what i
do there isn't there's not a single
[ __ ] one of you can crack a good joke
you know no i get the odd good word off
on stage not so much on youtube
you have your gifts that's not one of
them um
you
not a single one of you is funny
not a single one of you could have a
late night chat show you know uh that's
this cabaret comedy like johnny carson
you know
none of you
nobody has filled the void left by me
because i'm a once-in-a-generation
talent
and sorry to be egotistical but it's
just it is what it is
um nobody has filled that void which is
why i'm not worried about coming back to
it and coming out of retirement you know
and and refilling it myself but
something did happen to me and that's
that
i sort of gave up on
conservatives a little bit
and so when i do return it's going to be
very much more in the mold of a more
conventional comedian and that's
what i am
currently closing funding to do as we
speak down here in oklahoma
um
much more in the vein of a of an
entertainment figure and much much less
of the politics
so the effect might be a relief for you
well not really because i quite enjoyed
it but the effect of this hasn't been to
kill me
the effect of the cowardice of other
conservative media figures and the
conservative base
their failure to stick up for me in
february 2017.
the effect wasn't to kill me the effect
was to lose one of their greatest and
most effective champions
because i'm fine
i'm doing good okay so okay so let's
talk about that being fine so
i want to go back to i still have a
question about the the
older man younger man relationship issue
why don't we talk about something else
well
like
uh humor me for humor me for two more
minutes because there's actually
something i want to go with this
okay so
the the first issue is
where's the line property drawn in those
relationships is
as far as you're concerned with regards
to age
uh and where and where is it usually
drawn because those are now you're
trying to get me now you're trying to
get me in trouble i'm not i'm really not
i don't want to get you in trouble i and
i don't think there is a line to
properly be drawn because you're
basically just talking about talking
degrees of degeneracy at that point
aren't you um you know the fact that you
get saddled with this aberrant sexuality
and you then have to go out and make the
best of it um
the fact that you find this paternal or
avuncular dimension in a in a
relationship with an older man that may
also have a sexual component i mean this
is layer upon layer upon layer of
dysfunction so you're not going to get
me to say 10 years is the right gap
because none of it's the right gap it's
all [ __ ] up
what's the alternative
i don't know i mean partly partly
hypothetically i wish conversion therapy
marriage
i wish conversion therapy worked um at
least you've said that before
at least in the case of lesbians we know
that we can
push women back into back back with men
and most of them will be happier as a
result with men on the other hand some
of us are just gay
uh and
i'm not going to be drawn on what the
correct kind of
[ __ ] up dysfunction
experiences i wasn't i wasn't trying to
corner you you know
well i don't want to corner you this is
something i'm really curious about
because
you you made the case and you made a
strong case that relationships between
younger men and older men were very
common in the gay community and that
it's not me making the case that's an
established fact i mean every gay person
knows that that's got nothing to do with
me that's just me pointing out something
that every gay person knows which is
that when peop when people first become
sexually active or aware of their sexual
orientation or they first start to go
out on the scene or whatever they very
often form an attachment with an older
man it may just be somebody five years
older in some cases it's somebody a
little bit older than that
fair enough how often do you think that
that's happening at the age that it
happened to you
i think it happens all the time i think
it happens everywhere um and i think
it's
i think it's an inevitable result of
having a
an aberrant sexuality where you have to
seek out kind of alternative print
alternative
parental figures because yours aren't
fit for purpose for this particular part
of adolescence you know right but then
you just said too that
this isn't an objection that
you don't see a clear
ethical pathway forward out of that well
none of it's ethical i mean it's all
debased and degenerate but
how what what okay so that's so
what do you mean by that exactly because
i think there's an element of
predatoriness in almost every gay
interaction and relationship and this is
just one example where it is more
obvious and more uh visible
but i think that um
there is a a predatory component in
even even in gay friendships
you think about the way that um well
that might have something to do with the
more arguably with the more predatory
element of male sexuality right right
and you're going to talk about
undiscussable things right well you take
the controlling calming um
mediating influence of women out of the
equation and men just hype each other up
which is why they why gay men end up
promiscuous right because you're taking
out that um
that restraint right exactly restraints
look at what i was looking for you're
taking out the restraint that's
typically provided by the woman um
instead you can just you know whatever
so hypothetically that was supposed to
be solved at least in part by the
introduction of
like socially sanctioned monogamous
relationships right because i've had
friends i knew about heightened male
promiscuity among the homosexual
community and it's heightened by a
substantial margin and the liberal types
who i thought were reasonable and i
certainly don't think all of them are
made the claim to me that the reason for
that enhanced promiscuity was that all
the
male homosexual sexual activity had to
occur behind the scenes and that it was
impossible for for men that's a
ridiculous argument that's a ridiculous
argument male 1 male homosexual
promiscuity is obviously simply a
function of you know what happens when
you put two men together attracted to
one another and you don't have the
restraint um of a woman um
it's obvious and and also you cannot
successfully box
a transgressive sexual identity into
when we say hetero patriarchal
institutions like marriage uh and expect
gay people to just suddenly become you
know
normal monogamous whatever doesn't work
like that well it seemed to okay that's
fine so but it seemed to me that in some
sense
that well here's something else that is
no doubt going to cause trouble it
seemed to me that that was kind of part
of the bargain like wasn't that the
bargain that the the i always saw that
was part of the deal is that you know in
exchange for having this millstone
around your neck in exchange for the
in exchange for the terrible agony of
giving up fatherhood
which you know you can adopt and blah
blah blah but ultimately you know
basically it's like joining the
priesthood you know you give up
fatherhood
in exchange you get to participate in a
sort of taboo breaking transgressive
experimental life
that performs perhaps some kind of
societal function
might even perform an evolutionary
function
um and which you have the excitement of
the marginal
exactly and and and that's that's why i
mean i'm i am
the world's greatest hypocrite on one
subject and one subject only and that's
gay marriage um and that's because i
don't have the foggiest idea what i
think still even though i've i've got
one uh i'm under no illusions that it is
a union under
under the lord but i am i remain
politically against gay marriage despite
the fact that i got one because i met
somebody who completed me and i couldn't
think of anything else
to do but of course i would marry him um
so i'm very i'm
i'm a mess on that subject yeah that
that's definitely that's definitely a
mess
i make no claim to coherent logical
positions on that one subject that one
subject i'm a mess but the reason i
always
was so skeptical of gay marriage is that
it was it was robbing us of the one
thing that we had the one good cool
thing about being gay that you had in
exchange for the awful horror of not
being able to produce a child with the
person you love in the ordinary course
of
of sexual congress um
when you realize that and i don't think
a lot of gay people realize that ever
but i realized it quite early when you
realize that
you the bottom of your world drops out
and you have to do something else
you have to find a purpose and if your
purpose isn't going to be fatherhood um
this is why so many gay men join the
priesthood because they want to be a
different kind of father uh you know
they want they want to to be um to be a
shepherd uh
you have to find some other kind of
purpose and very often for gay men
that's uh
creativity experimentation yeah it's the
license that we're given by the rest of
society um because we
we don't have this other thing
um
trying to cram
again i'm a complete hypocrite on the
subject because i live in total married
bliss i live in
i live in beautiful monogamous domestic
harmony uh so i'm a 100 percent
hypocrite on the subject but it just it
still feels to me a shame to just sort
of condemn you know
our experimenters you know the people
who are so overrepresented in artists
and musicians and and even politicians
and warlords you know uh to sort of
condemn them to the same you know
the same monotonous drudgery that you
breeders have to have to submit to um
yes well i can imagine that it's sort of
it sort of grates against your
what would you call it your your
anti-authoritarian
my rebellious spirit and all the rest of
it yeah yeah i'm i'm
kind of poetic justice in some sense
yeah yeah
this is this is one of the many things
that that convinces me that god is real
because there's no there's no
there's there's a humor in that which
could only have come from someone doing
it on purpose you know just being like
you know what i'm going to give i'm
going to give you something that's just
going to make just going to remind you
that you don't know it all uh and you
and it's going to confound you for the
rest of your life and remind you that
you two are messy and complicated and on
this one subject you are never going to
be coherent or logical um good luck with
that
okay so no doubt what's up i have
another terrible question for you
so i i read um
martell's book on the catholic church
about homosexuality in the vatican and
it's very
um
contentious book let's say written by a
gay man who claims that
homosexuality is
extraordinarily common in the vatican it
is and so and that the kinds of
relationships that you describe between
older men and younger men are common in
that culture as they're calling in the
rest of the culture yes they are
so i've written a book on the subject
too uh and i can tell you for a fact
that both of those things are true
there's it's called um the lavender
mafia uh in the vatican it is uh the the
um
uh for those those viewers who don't
know um it is a cabal of not just gay
bishops but specifically progressive
left-wing gay bishops
yes and and my book was a little bit
more politically focused than his my
book was drawing attention to the fact
that the same people who want to water
down the liturgy who want um
for you know divorcees to be able to
receive communion and want you know gay
people to do whatever they're the same
people who've been covering up child
abuse in the church and and it seems
that the same people who have been doing
the child abuse and covering it up are
also the people who are most
aggressively pushing for progressive
reform
um of the catholic liturgy and of
catholic practice and this of course
resonates with what we know from other
industries doesn't it just like
hollywood just like the press just like
the academy the people who are most
aggressively pushing for um progressive
free-for-all sexual liberation other
people with the
ugliest and most depraved skeletons in
the closet the rest of us are quite
normal you know so
um my book was more about that but i can
tell you that um it's absolutely true
the mistake that the catholic church has
made
um and i remain a catholic
despite the terrible state
of the catholic church
um yes and all the other contradictions
in your life
you know
they've never bothered me they've never
scared me i'm not i'm not afraid of that
i'm quite excited by that because i look
forward to a day when i might grow
either get closer to a resolution or be
happy with you know with not finding one
doesn't
i mean you know i can i can imagine i
can imagine ben shapiro would be kept
awake at night by this but i'm not you
know because i don't need everything in
my world to form into a perfectly you
know into like some sort of like canteen
or vicinian superstructure uh where
everything has its right place and you
know and everything is perfectly
organized and all the dependent things
are in the right
that's not what human beings are like
that's not what we are um we're much
much more complex and messy than that
and i'm i'm very much looking forward to
40 50 years of exploring my own
ludicrous you know
internal nonsense
but
the the the
i remain i remain catholic but the issue
that the church has had the mistake that
the church has made is turning a blind
eye
as the church would put it to sin um
turning a blind eye to
rampant gay sex in a vocation that is
supposed to be celibate supposed to be
chased um
and whenever you associate that
hypothetically well the way that you
martel's claim with the proclivity to
cover up the child sexual abuse because
of it which is his most radical claim i
would say i i don't know if he's wrong
about that what i would say is
the way that the way the church would
put it is you know if you make room for
one sin others will follow right so
what that means in practical terms for
the catholic church is
because the priesthood is somewhere
where lots of gay men go and a blind eye
is routinely turned to their sexual
peccadillos even if it's just with each
other and there's nothing um
non-consensual or abusive going on
because it's a sexual free-for-all
because it's the kind of place where
supposedly transgressive or forbidden
things happen routinely with no
consequence
that it becomes an institution that
attracts other kinds of people who have
other things to hide like pedophiles
where are you going to go if you have
some kind of of
psychiatric dysfunction or whatever it
is like that you're going to go
somewhere that routinely overlooks or
ignores sexual
wrongdoing of course you are that's what
the church that's what that's what
christians mean when they say you know
you let one sin and others will follow
they don't just mean it in the
sense of personal behavior like if you
let yourself do one thing you'll let
yourself do others but it also works in
institutions too and of course the
lefties will say the reason that all of
these problems happen in the catholic
church is that priests are required to
be celibate the opposite's true they
haven't been celebrated for a very long
time and that's what's created the
problem because there's now
an entrenched left-wing gay mafia that
effectively runs the catholic church
that has engaged in the systematic
cover-up of child abuse so as to protect
its own power
and that's
about as bad as it gets you know in
terms of you know global institutions
who have lost their way that is as
it gets
uh i want a black pope because i want um
i want there to be
a doctrinally conservative because all
of the the catholics in africa are like
pre-vatican too they're serious
catholics
um and it will make it make life very
difficult for progressives accusing a
black pope from africa or being a racist
and a sexist you know because he
actually wants catholic doctrine to
remain catholic doctrine but the present
pope is um
basically
he is not himself homosexual as far as
we know but he does sit at the head of
um this
lavender mafia um and he is propped up
by people like uh um
uh cormac murphy o'connor uh from
england and wales vincent nichols and
all these other um aging 60 70 year old
liberal cardinals who are products of
the 60s who are
soft on communism
and and
what my book was trying to show was that
the soft on communism thing is entwined
with the abuse with the wrongdoing with
everything they're the same people doing
everything so theodore mccarrick who has
the distinction of being the world's
only ex-cardinal because um francis had
to remove his
um his cardinality from him uh had to
degrade him as the technical term he was
um
francis's envoy to china
and he was the one who put the deal
together with francis to allow the
chinese state
to participate in the choice
in choosing catholic bishops
i mean this hasn't happened since like
gregory the seventh the catholic church
has been ferocious about choosing its
own bishops but they handed selection of
the bishops over to the communist party
in china
knowing that catholics are routinely
persecuted um you know and killed in
china um because they they never met a
socialist they didn't like
and it's that
it's that particular 60 70 year old
child of the 60s aging hippie liberal
that
lives in another planet from the rest of
us and is still thinking you know if
only they
sorry there's some lawnmower oklahoma um
if only if only socialism were tried one
more time perhaps perhaps it would be
okay this time that's the world these
people live in um and they also that's
in your book pope
it's uh it's yeah this is called
diabolical uh how pope francis portrayed
clerical abuse victims like me and why
he has to go uh it's called diabolical
so yeah but anyway okay i talk about
that in books i'm not not here but um
but no it's it's very interesting how
the same people who are far leftists who
are pushing for church doctrine to be
watered down which has the effect of
emptying the pews because when people go
to church they want the fire and
brimstone they go to be told what to do
they want the bible they want jesus they
don't want climate change right right
they don't you know they don't want they
don't want a bishop talking to them and
i'm not making this up there are
seminaries now where the um
where the seminarians are starting to to
issue um
uh
they're starting to give sermons on
toxic masculinity this is a church that
is that has no no manly men left in it
yeah every man in that church is a home
mum you know there are no men left in
the congregations there are no
heterosexual men left in the clergy and
this is the church that thinks it has a
too many men problem you know
um
this is a church that and the reason
that this subject interested me in
addition to my
faith is that this is another arena in
which the loss of manliness and
masculinity and the loss of a proper
appreciation of the heroic masculine
virtues has led to chaos and disaster
because no
true father by which i mean the sorts of
fatherhood that the priests are supposed
to um
give up having children in order to to
to embark upon you know no no spiritual
leader um
with integrity would stand by and watch
children being abused and cover it up
this is something that gay people do
because they think what they do is wrong
so they're happy to cover for somebody
else who's doing something wrong too
a father a real father doesn't sip idly
by while children are being abused
he takes you know he takes steps to stop
it and he punishes the people who have
done wrong
that's the righteous indignation and
outrage of a true father and those
and that that appreciation of you know
like it's it's right and proper to hate
the hateful and we should be outraged
about it well you said that's part of
what you've learned over the last couple
of years right and but that heroic manly
virtue is something that has been sort
of systematically wiped out of the
catholic church just like it's been
wiped out of other
uh places in public life yeah it's gone
from journalism like it's gone from
academy and it's results that everybody
knows about in all those different
arenas so it was interesting to me
writing the book finding that
most of the problems
most of the
things that are happening in the
catholic church most of the problems the
church has got itself into basically
boil down to there being no men
it's all women and gays and the vast
majority of the child abuse scandal and
all the other things that are wrong with
the catholic church are a product of
the church losing its connection to
masculinity and simply having no men
left in it oh good well good there's
nothing controversial about any of that
so that's quite a relief
so
we can we
we don't have to be in peril that was a
joke
just so you know that i can actually
pull one off okay so i want to return to
something if you don't mind
i want you to tell me
what you think the consequences of what
happened to you when you were 14 might
have been
okay
i don't know
yes
i mean look if you're not like if
i'm not i'm not
unwilling to discuss it with you yep i'm
not having a problem being forthcoming
yeah i just don't know
i know the only thing that i've really
thought about
is whether or not it might have affected
the trajectory of my sexuality
and i think that it may well have done
but i don't think it on its own was
enough to make a difference
i think i'm probably right about that
also talked about
just in this conversation about the
transgressive nature of
that
sexuality
and now you participated in that even
it's let's say as an active participant
and the question is
what did that do to you
what what did that what did the
knowledge of that do to you because you
had to live with it
i don't know if it's a fair question i
don't know if i'm freezing
no no you're phrasing it fine i just
don't know the answer to it
um in the same way that i don't think
anybody can know
what quote unquote made them gay you
know it's like everybody has is born
with i think um everybody is born with a
more or less of a predilection whether
or not you believe in epigenetics or
whatever um some people do some people
don't but i think everybody probably has
a sort of predisposition
uh and coupled with early experiences
you end up either mostly having sex with
men or not right um
i don't think that we're ever
conscious of the processes acting on us
at the time and therefore it's very
difficult
it's just pure speculation based on
whatever we happen to remember
trying to work out what it was that made
the difference
and i don't think it's i don't think
it's something that could ever
satisfactorily be answered because
simply because we're just not aware of
the processes acting on us i don't know
if
my dad not saving me from you know that
household made me
you know sort of
made some kind of misfire rewired like
you know i
said something haywire in my brain i
don't know whether i resented and just
you know just like my mother so much
that i went off all women i don't know
and i don't think there's ever any way
to know and for the same reason i don't
think there's any way that i could
possibly answer and i don't think
there's anything anybody could be on
blind speculation and i think that most
people who are
most people who try to explain i'm so
sorry somebody's mowing the lawn um
most people who try to explain what
abuse might have done to somebody
in almost every case
i see their political prejudices and
their biases at work yeah you know out
there in search of justification because
the truth is
i have no i have no god damn idea and
neither does anybody else
no one can possibly have a clue because
these things are acting below the
conscious level on us in a way that we
cannot
dissect and analyze okay okay all right
so let's let me let me ask you then let
me switch topics so
you know you've been less in the public
eye
since
this
scam i'm retired i've been retired
you've been retired okay
but you probably used your book look i
sold a quarter million books i made
millions of dollars i have more
nice stuff than i know what to do with i
have a
husband i am deeply in love with i could
die happy tomorrow i helped to get a
present in office i'm one of the seven
people that put trump in office and
that's not egotism that's a fact right
i'm one of the seven people that put
donald trump in office i can die happy
now is it
it might be too in purgatory for you as
a consequence yeah no i mean maybe you
know what happens after i die for that
particular crime who knows but um
but the fact is like i have accomplished
more than the vast majority of people
walking this earth
i have you know and if i were to do
nothing else professionally now
i would be infinitely more successful in
all of my critics combined okay so so
i'm good so there's there's rumors of
your current state there's rumors that
you're terribly indebted there's there's
rumors okay so i sometimes you know
one of the problems with trying to find
out what's true about me is i like to
troll journalists and i i confirm or
deny according to my whimsy so when
somebody writes to me saying is it true
or two million in doubt i'll say no
darling it's four million um what i
won't what i won't
uh go to the trouble of explaining is
that of my many companies the one that
was funded by the nurses who withdrew
their political investments from steve
bannon and for me at the same time that
particular vehicle is somewhat in debt
but i'm not
i don't
i don't have any personal liability
whatsoever the sum total of the money i
owe is about 977 dollars to capital one
because i can't get any better credit
cards in there because i haven't been in
this country for long enough i've seen
um so so it's a corporate problem rather
than i might not have as much money as i
had two years ago um i don't but um i'm
not two million in debt
one of my companies is um and we'll
probably have to either try to fight it
will have to fight its way out of that
or it will have to you know go through
some kind of insolvency process or
whatever but
i am not in debt i just never bothered
to correct the record and frankly when a
journalist if a journalist wrote to me
so sorry about the noise if a journalist
wrote to me and said are you two million
dare and i made the very important
critical distinction between me
and the business yes they wouldn't write
that up anyway that's that they would
take my confirmation of the figure as
confirmation that i'm in debt and just
write what they wanted to anyway so i
feel no i mean it's not a crime to lie
to journalists and i feel no obligation
to uh
to act as their fact-checking i think
it's actually a crime to tell the truth
to journalists isn't it amen amen no if
somebody comes fleeting like a crime
often if somebody comes to me to ask for
comment i think it's a moral obligation
to [ __ ] with them um which is why i got
myself into trouble that time before you
know when someone shot up the the
newsroom wherever wherever it was
because i i made some flippant comment
about vigilante death squads and
journalists or something and i didn't
post it publicly i wasn't like inciting
people to hurt journalists i wrote it
to somebody who then published it and
wrote a story about it and then they
used that as evidence that i was ginning
up like people whatever
this is the these are some of the
consequences of being the kind of person
who can't fight their lip glow can't
hold their tongue right right my job
so my job is to create a career in which
that doesn't matter
because i'm not
um
because my success
my income my fan base my profile
whatever
isn't reliant on
the prestige economy but it's also not
reliant on
the sort of rules of journalistic
propriety or whatever so this is why um
i'm in the
reason i'm in oklahoma is i'm closing
the last tranche of money to do um a
late night chat show like johnny carter
this is the thing i alluded to earlier
in the conversation i see i see so
that's part of your future plans and who
are you who are you doing with if you
don't mind me asking are you still in
the process of waiting to announce that
i'm i haven't announced anything yet so
i'm getting the money in the bank first
and then i'll do all my hires and then
i'll you know announce partners and all
the rest of it but the the the basic
the idea of it is what i should always
have been doing which is
somewhere between bill maher and and
johnny carson i can do my characters i
can do my ill genome my doctor christine
kind of characters uh as cold opens like
snl except they'll actually be funny i
can do monologues i can do interviews
all the rest of it and i'm a live act
i'm not one of these people that can
just babble for three hours a day like
you know some of the podcasters can do
some of the youtubers can do i just find
it so boring you know i don't want to
just babble three hours like no one
wants to hear the same opinions from the
same four conservatives on the news
every day it's just it's
mind-numbingly dull that's not me i'm a
writer and a live act right that's where
i live that's my happy place
so it'll just be once a week and so how
are you going to how are you going to
protect yourself just out of curiosity
about being
from being censored and taken out like
because i'm going to make it
i'm going to make it absolutely
anti-fragile we're not going to be on
social media we are going to encourage
viewers not to share clips we're going
to beg people not to put us on social
media we're going to host the video on
our own player on our own website
um if you want to watch it put your
email address in and what we can sell
into the email list right so we can you
know do
newsletters with offers and all the rest
of it
so it's something approximating a
private subscription service
yes it isn't completely dissimilar from
alex jones's model um just without the
homegrown products
right well that's what we're hoping to
allow people to do with this platform
that we've been building as an
alternative to patreon
you know on a broader scale well maybe
i'll be on that because if you'll have
me because um this is the only thing i'm
not banned from perhaps
uh i think these hermetically sealed
little universes are the future for us
look social media isn't for isn't for us
the people who run these companies hate
us they are dedicated to our
annihilation they want to see us wiped
off the face of the planet there's no
point handing distribution over to
people who hate and why would you drive
up the market value of these companies
by providing them free content just
leave
and i'm always the person who has to do
it two years before everybody else so
this is what i'm gonna do just just
leave social media i'm gonna spend a
bunch of money uh converting my facebook
fans into a big powerful email list and
i'm just gonna leave there will be life
after social media trust me once once
upon a time people didn't imagine that
there would be no the myspace wouldn't
still be here there was aol geocities
the world moves on and in five years no
one will have a twitter account anymore
and you'll be worrying you'll be
wondering what on earth you were
panicking about and the people who
didn't look ahead will be lost
i will have a three million strong email
list that i write to every day with you
know a hilarious um daily column
and they'll tune in on friday nights to
watch my show and i'll be perfectly
happy nobody can take that away from me
you know if we email providers timeline
for that what how how when when are you
expecting to roll that out approximately
um i've kind of pretty much sort of semi
told people already so the cat's kind of
sort of out of the bag so i haven't
really broken the news now but but um
once the money's in the bank then i'll
say
then it'll be six to eight weeks before
we have a set built uh so two months
before we drop
i'm going to have a very open
gestation process i'm going to show
pictures of the set while it's being
built all the rest of it we're not going
to do like grand announcements because
i've done enough of those in my career
um so we'll just have a very iterative
uh period of
putting every assembling everything and
then in about two months i will drop
episode one and it will be
the funniest
most hilarious unmissable hour of
television that's somehow not on tv
um
produced by anybody in the country
and it will be unmissable and hysterical
uh it will teach you something because
we'll have a serious component too
whether it's a mini documentary or an
interview or a review of something and
it'll be bookended by just the funniest
political satire and you know and
and characters and nonsense um but that
nobody can do but me uh and
it's sort of what i always should have
done it's what i've always wanted to do
uh and now i have the breathing space if
you like well no one's looking well no
one's expecting daily this that the
other for me i'm in my you know
in my first retirement period well i
share i will come out over time and many
times in my life um
this is um i've i've had this nice space
where no one's been kind of down my neck
to deliver it have you enjoyed that like
has there been anything about advantages
to you about the fact that you've been
sort of pulled away from the public
spotlight it's been wonderful it's been
wonderful i've been able to i've been
able to dedicate two years of my life to
getting to know the man i'm going to
spend the rest of my life with you know
and now we can go about
now i'll throw myself back into the
fight he's got his own career and all
the rest of it but we've had something
that most married couples don't get
which is two years just together at the
beginning of our life together most
people don't have that luxury uh or
anything even close to it they
immediately get bogged down in the
everyday hell of you know who's taking
the kids to school did you pay the gas
bill crap right we didn't have any of
that we just had two years of bliss
together and now we have an unshakable
foundation and if i'm away for six
months i'm away for six months and it
won't make a difference to us because we
don't have the same sort of
vulnerabilities that a lot of newlywed
couples do because we had that that time
together so from to my mind it was time
well spent i've also been reading a lot
and we didn't get to talk about anything
really substantive in this conversation
except my
obscure
psychiatric history but um
you will see you will see that i've been
reading a lot and sharpening my claws
and
uh
refilling my tool kit and so when i
do start
re-entering the arena and popping up on
live streams and doing interviews and
things like that you'll see that um i've
spent two years reading everything i can
get my hands on and i'm
considerably more formidable than i was
two years ago and i was already quite
formidable anything you'd particularly
recommend
not at the moment i'm going to keep my
powder dry because i have uh i have
lots of fun things that i want to that i
want to do with it all um but no i've
i've been regrouping and plotting
and sharpening my knives and you don't
want to be you know you don't want to be
the first one in front of my blades um
no it's it's
people keep expecting me to be sad or to
have had some kind of terrible
experience and the truth is i just
haven't i've had the best two years of
my life i've been i've been in perfect
bliss with the best man i've ever met
and now i'm ready to get back to
work all right well look
that sounds like a good place to end
from as far as i'm concerned that was
the nice natural solution wasn't it that
was that was natural perhaps we could
perhaps we could do this again and talk
about something substantive instead of
instead of my
dreadful history
yeah well you know you're an interesting
character and so
it was substantive as far as i was
concerned and i think people will find
it that too
so
what happened to you was very
singular
and but it is unexpected it's important
that people realize that um
the the specifics of what was said are
neither here or there
it was the fact that
the the powers that be linked up and
decided to defenestrate this person
and because
conservatives allowed it to happen they
lost one of their greatest champions
and i'm going to be very successful with
very profitable enterprises and
perfectly happy just being funny for a
living because
i sort of think to myself
why would i keep killing myself for
people
people who
don't deserve me so
to some degree the politics stuff it's
never going to be gone but it is going
to be dialed down considerably and i'm
going to be talking about love sex death
and money instead of you know
trump or whatever yeah well maybe you
spent you know maybe you spend enough
time talking about politics
it's not very interesting after a while
and the people who are in politics are
awful
i mean if those of us who are kind of
moving into that political sphere and
who have you know aspirations toward
being elected officials the rest of it
they're becoming awful people i mean
everyone in politics is is
dreadful ghastly
i don't think i want to spend 30 years
talking about or thinking about those
people i mean i think i want to do
something more fun
um so yeah i'm gonna i mean not to say
that there won't be uh
characters from the political world
popping up in my sketches but um or
indeed that i want to
of course i'm gonna do journalism it
just won't necessarily be political
journalism per se so perhaps i'll do a
20-minute mini documentary in the show
where i'll go out into the country
somewhere or i'll go to sweden or i'll
go to london or whatever but
um
but as far as the sort of you know the
conservative movement stuff goes the
conservative base are cowards and they
are ungrateful and they are indolent um
and
i
gave a lot
and paid my dues and helped get a
president in office and now it's time to
do what i want to do which is make
people laugh
because that's that's the power that i
have that nobody else in our world does
um so i'm going to focus on that yeah
it's a hell of a power
really can make people laugh you know
i think he makes heterosexual men a
certain kind of heterosexual man laugh
well that's something you know there are
certain kinds of heterosexual i like the
i like the guy but i i don't personally
find him you know rib ticklingly funny
um but then that's because i like people
like joan rivers and you know right
right right you know uh that kind of
universe
so uh
you know bill burr or whatever uh so
he's he's maybe not my kind of comedian
anything could be could be um but
anyway this has been fun so thanks um
hey look i've been looking forward to
talking to you for a long time oh and uh
say hi to vox for me
i will i will he's very much looking
forward to me speaking to you too
um this is that's what i want to talk
about i want to talk about things like
the forward because there's interesting
substantive things to do that you've
managed look we'll have it and i know
this is your stretch another
conversation well we will and you this
is your strategy through this
conversation which is not lost on me was
to make sure that we don't spend too
much time talking about you and you have
been successful in that strategy because
i've allowed you to but the next
conversation we will talk about you um
because i do want to talk about uh the
forward and i do want to talk about some
of the things that you know the thing
that i asked you about on australian tv
and whatever because i think that um
well turnabout is fair play as they say
right and i knew you know i did
apologize to you honestly that's it and
i'm and i'm i'm
i did make a mistake at the
tonight and i experienced apology and
thank you for that um
no i i um i think there's
important substance to be spoken about
you know as regards
well important things garden yeah
there's what else so let's talk about
let's talk about real things next time
well i think i think when i when i'm
feeling particularly um up to a battle
i'll think about then i'm sure a lot of
people will watch this so this is
officially the last time i will ever
speak about bloody february 2017. um so
if anybody wants to know anything you
can watch this video and that's it
all right
good
well
best of luck with your new endeavor
cheers best of luck to you take care all
right bye bye